this week's honest trailer is brought to
you by d d beyond d d is for everyone d
d beyond makes it easy to play register
for free at d beyond.com to start your
adventure
jolie is in a new movie this week and
that's all the excuse we need to crack
open the honest trailer vault to
re-watch her very first film
tron took us inside the computer war
game showed us how powerful they could
be
but now one film will show us what the
bleeding edge of today's tech is all
about one-on-one cartoon techno virus
fighting is that all you got huh
come on let's see what else you can do
is that what windows 95 is going to be
like because i am so in got a boy an
entire gallery of cats owners photos
they have an audio tour with this
hackers
meet dade murphy who grew from a boy who
looks too young to play 12 to a man who
looks too old to play 17. he's the only
teenager to ever get bombed about moving
to new york i'm sorry we had to move in
your senior year wow that's a lot of
suds but this man baby's got a secret
he's secretly not cool and i'm still a
virgin also he's secretly zero cool a
hacker who crashed 1507 computer systems
at once a fact they'll remind you of
about 1507 times his computer virus
crashed 1507
systems crashed 1507 systems in one day
1500 systems in one day 1507 and when he
moves to the big apple he'll join a
secret society of computer hackers where
everyone goes by a cool hacker name my
name is the plague i'm the freak the
phantom freak meet serial killer your
asset burn lord nikon this is crash
override and gets together to watch cool
hacker tv shows hangs out at hacker
clubs that might as well be the foot
clan hideout from ninja turtles and
pulls off their hacks in public while
dressed like techno clowns hey wait a
minute they aren't keeping this hacking
stuff secret at all no wonder they get
caught about 1507 times
watch a film where everyone dresses like
a spice girl a radio shack those pagers
are the bomb yo but no one pulls off a
rash guard slacks and combat boots like
jon voigt's daughter newcomer angelina
jolly stars as acid burn a girl who
combines the riot girl attitude of the
90s with the human sex trophy role of an
80s movie but man i think i'm in love i
am so glad catherine hygo turned this
down to do under siege 2 dark territory
rounding out this crew of
unrealistically hot nerds is cereal who
i'm pretty sure is homeless can i crash
your place tonight again so what do you
think i crashed your place tonight freak
the guy you call when you want to make a
call please deposit five dollars for the
first minute
thank you little joey who can hack two
cigarettes at the same time and lord
nikon who uses his photographic memory
in the creepiest ways possible lisa
blair 26 east 7th street apartment 16
555-4817
watch fischer stevens chew the scenery
and also some bizarre green candy as the
plague an evil version of his character
from short circuit he'll be hacking the
hackers as this hacker who hacked his
way into a big corporation runs a big
hack that he can play on our hero small
hack or something like that and if that
computer talk gets too confusing don't
worry half the characters are just as
dumb as you are you know anything about
computers um could you uh read me the
number on the modem um
what's happening a rabbit is in the
administration system send a flu shot
rabbit flu shot someone talk to me
they're going for the curdle colonel who
the system command processor it's the
brain cancer brain brain cancer what's
going on we got an uncorrupted hard
drive
in english leads and even then don't
worry because hacking is either like
doing math on shrooms
or playing a flight sim on the brand new
sony playstation now available at
circuit city
damn this makes me want to crank some
chemical brothers and slam a sixer of
jolt now where's that aol trial disc
daddy needs some more hours
so experience a film with an exciting
new vision of the future because these
kids aren't just committing petty crimes
that probably hurt a lot of people
and they almost set a cop on fire
[Music]
no these hackers are showing us the way
to a new era of freedom because when we
go online we free ourselves from
consumerism
racism and get to express ourselves
however we want without it getting back
to our school or employer
so laugh all you want but this movie has
two predictions guaranteed to come true
one the internet is going to bring about
a society where everyone is equal we
exist without nationality skin color or
religious bias that's cool and two
everyone is going to rollerblade
everywhere i mean how could we not it's
so much faster than feet
starring
date and confused 28-point kate modem
retaining order
cereal and milk earthquake
narc anthony
hypebeast 1.0
business in the front lan party in the
back oh sick is that a power glove
radical hi i'm ben this is my partner
hacker floppy discs and hack the planet
hack the planet
[Applause]
[Music]
wow she's a ventriloquist too
this week's honest trailer is brought to
you by dnd beyond dnd beyond makes it
easy to play register for free at
dndbeyond.com to start your adventure
i am the watcher i cannot interfere but
i can give brutally honest reviews
everyone hail to the pumpkin king